The only thing I knew about
wasps before this video
was that they are those flying insects that
hover round picnics and sting people.
That was it. I assumed, naively,
that wasps had no useful role
in the world's ecosystem.
So when someone from the
Oregon Department of Agriculture
got in touch and said that they
send out taxpayer-funded wasps...
I had some questions.
Like... why?
- This is pest control at a
ecosystem-wide level.
There are hundreds of thousands
of species of wasp
and only a handful of those
actually sting people.
The vast, vast majority of them
go about their entire life,
and you never see them or notice them.
- Around the turn of the century,
the brown marmorated stink bug
arrived in the United States.
It's originally from East Asia,
but enough of them had been
carried in accidentally by global trade
that a breeding population started
and then exploded.
Those stink bugs are now found
across most of the continent,
and they consume crops like
apples, pears, hazelnuts and soybeans,
causing millions of dollars
in damage every year.
- They are a generalist pest.
They feed on hundreds of
different plant species,
and they have a great range of
climatic conditions
that they're perfectly happy
to live in.
Its populations have reproduced
without anything to check it.
- So what you want is the
stink bug’s natural enemy:
which is a particular type of wasp,
that's being bred inside this chamber.
- Parasitoid wasps attack other insects
and lay their eggs
inside of them to reproduce.
Sometimes that's an insect egg.
Sometimes they eat the insect alive,
starting at the least vital organs first.
This is where the inspiration for
the chest-burster from Alien came from.
We breed the stink bugs because the
parasitoid wasps need them to reproduce in.
As many stink bug eggs as we have
is about as many wasps as we can produce.
Last year we produced around 20,000,
and the year before that
we produced around 17,000.
- And they are tiny! I didn’t realise
until I got here and saw them
that you could get wasps that
are only about a millimetre long.
They’re so delicate that the researchers
can't use tweezers to move them around.
they have to gently suck them up
through chiffon fabric
using the housing of a ballpoint pen.
But human intervention in ecosystems
doesn't have a great history,
so my next question was: well,
how do they know what
to release and where?
- Researchers from USDA
and different universities
went to Asia to find out
what attacks it in Asia,
and why is it not such
a big problem there.
They brought Trissolcus japonicus
back over to the United States
into quarantine facilities,
tested it on North American species
to see if there were any that
we didn't test in Asia,
that it could also attack.
Decades of work go into making sure
that the wasps that we're
releasing are also safe.
If we give it brown marmorated
stink bug eggs and any other stink bug,
it'll choose brown marmorated stink bug
95+% of the time.
But if you give it just
another stink bug egg mass,
it will use it if there's
no other choice.
So we were actually a little
on the fence about
whether or not we wanted to release it.
And then it showed up anyways.
- After years and years of work,
the wasps showed up anyway,
because every year,
millions of flights land
and millions of shipping containers
arrive at ports,
and it's not like those are sterile.
So, now that the fight is being set up
out in the wild anyway:
why do they still breed and release these?
- The parasitoid wasp needs
some time to catch up.
It's around a millimeter and a half long.
It can't fly very far.
We can drive it a lot further than
it can fly in a single year.
So we actually get those populations started
without having to fly across
the entire state of Oregon.
Normally the growers reach out to
the Department of Agriculture
and we go out to a site visit.
Not every site is suitable for these wasps.
They're actually nectar feeders and pollinators,
so they actually do need other plants present.
They can provide permanent, long-lasting
pest control for not just growers,
but the entire ecosystem.
These do not sting people.
I have worked with not only this wasp, but other
wasps that are much larger than it
that are parasitoid wasps,
and I have never been stung,
and I've been working on these
for over a decade.